la douleur vous connaissez c'est à la
fois un truc nul un truc fascinant et un
truc qui concerne tout le monde enfin
presque tout le monde mais on va en
reparler un petit peu plus tard et les
trucs et un petit peu bizarre c'est
évidemment la douleur tout le monde sait
ce que c'est mais le phénomène en
réalité il n'est pas si bien connu que
ça et pourtant il ya plein de trucs à
dire dessus donc j'ai décidé de faire
une série de vidéos sur le sujet une
série qui n'a pas encore de nom donc
comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à me
donner aux idées dans les commentaires
bon on y va on y va
[Musique]
donc pour cette première vidéo sur le
sujet on va poser les bases avec guy
trucs à savoir sur la douleur mais avant
ça juste un petit mot pour vous rappeler
que vous avez toujours une réduction
chez panda kraft panda kraft vous
souvenez il avait sponso ma vidéo sur
les effets du dérèglement climatique sur
la santé cds kit éducatif pour les
enfants avec des expériences à réaliser
des objets à construire et un magazine à
chaque fois sur un thème différent la
dernière fois que vous en avez parlé
c'était sur l'environnement donc là en
août c'était sur les engins spatiaux en
ce moment c'est sur le cerveau et le
mois prochain ce sera sur les illusions
d'optique mais ça on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler voilà donc apprendre à
kraft explore pour les 3 à 7 ans panda
kraft makers pour les 8 à 12 ans ça
coûte 10 euros par mois c'est sans
engagement et vous avez 15 % de
réduction sur les différentes formules
d'abonnement avec le code dans ton corps
je vous mets le lien dans la description
met donc la douleur alors et bats la
douleur c'est complexe oui la douleur
c'est complexe c est complexe parce que
un peu comme toutes les manifestations
de notre corps c'est vrai ça d
implication physique mais aussi des
composantes psychique et sociale et puis
parce que c'est à la fois une histoire
de perception et de sensations la
perception passé le signal électrique
c'est le message qui est transmis à
notre cerveau par les neurones quand ils
sont stimulés par un truc qui fait mal
et la sensation c'est l'analyse que
notre cerveau fait de ce message et ça
ça varie d'une personne à l'autre donc
si je vous dis que la douleur c'est un
stimulus un truc qui coupent qui piquent
qui brûlent etc qui excite des
terminaisons nerveuses de neurones
spécialisés dans la douleur qu'on
appelle nos six des septs heures ou
récepteur nocifs et tiff ces récepteurs
de la douleur on en a partout on en a
sur la peau sur nos muscles au niveau de
nos articulations de nos organes etc il
y en a de plusieurs sortes et il réagit
soit quand il détecte une agression
mécanique c'est à dire des formations de
la peau arch aucune pénétration objets
etc soit les trucs thermique c'est à
dire les trucs très chaud ou les trucs
très froid et ils peuvent réagir aussi
quand il détecte la présence de
certaines substances chimiques si je
vous dis que ces neurones transmettent
ensuite le message électrique jusqu'à la
moelle épinière ou il va se passer deux
choses d'abord il a déclenché un réflexe
qu'on appelle un réflexe de sauvegarde
en gros qui va servir faire stopper le
stimulus douloureux genre en retirant sa
main de la plaque de cuisson par exemple
ou de n'importe quel truc qui est en
train de nous brûler et puis il ya un
nouveau message qui va être créée et qui
va être envoyée cette fois jusqu'au
cerveau et le cerveau va l'analyser à
peu près de la façon suivante
aïeux voilà c'est la douleur si je vous
dis ça et bah je vous dis pas tout parce
que il n'y a pas qu'une seule sorte de
douleur déjà il ya des douleurs aiguës
c'est à dire celles qui font mal une
fois et puis qui se calme
progressivement soi quand on soigne la
cause soit quand on attend un peu et
puis elle est où leur chronique celle
qui dure plus de trois mois et qu'on a
du mal à calmer mes oncles associe la
douleur en trois types différents en
fonction de leur cause il ya la douleur
no 6 et petits ve
celle que je vous ai décrites 1 juste
avant c'est celle qu'on connaît mieux
qui arrive par exemple quand on a pris
un coup quand on s'est brûlé ou quand on
a une inflammation quelque part il ya
aussi les douleurs neuropathiques cela
elles sont causées par une atteinte du
système nerveux donc c'est à dire les
nerfs le cerveau ou la moelle épinière
et puis allez douleur centralisée qui
sont dues à un problème au niveau des
centres de traitement de la douleur on
les appelle aussi les douleurs
dysfonctionnelle on ajoute parfois un
quatrième type de douleur les douleurs
psychogène engrossé des douleurs qui
apparaissent par exemple dans un
contexte de dépression ou de grande
anxiété mais pour lesquels on ne trouve
pas de causes physiques évidentes des
douleurs de dos par exemple gens
revendent à une sciatique mais quand on
fait une irm tout est normal alors petit
aparté pour ça déjà il ya le risque
qu'une douleur soit classé là dedans
juste parce qu'on comprend pas trop ce
qui se passe vous savez le fameux wii
bompas et psychosomatiques quoi et puis
deuxième chose une douleur psychogène
c'est dans la tête oui si on veut mais
c'est une vraie douleur donc il faut la
soigner et oui il ya des moyens de
soigner les douleurs psychogène on aura
l'occasion de reparler de tout ça dans
une prochaine vidéo sur le sujet mais
retenez en tout cas que évidemment on ne
soigne pas les différents types de
douleur de la même façon et donc la
douleur c'est complexe parce qu'il ya
plusieurs types de douleur mais aussi
parce que tout le monde ne ressent pas
la douleur de la même façon la douleur
c'est pas un gros truc comme ça d'un
bloc qui serait le même pour tout le
monde déjà on vient de voir qu'ils en
avaient plusieurs sortes mais en plus on
estime que la douleur est là quatre
composantes qui susceptible de la faire
varier et notamment de la faire varier
d'une personne à l'autre via la
composante sensitive d'abord celle qui
dépend de notre capacité à analyser la
douleur qu'on ressent quel genre de
douleur c'est à quel endroit sa durée
son intensité et s'est ensuite la
composante affective et émotionnelle
celle qui dépend du contexte de la
douleur et notamment de l'état dans
laquelle est la personne qu'il a subie
l'angoissent ou la dépression par
exemple ça aggrave la douleur il ya
aussi la composante cognitives c'est à
dire tout ce qui est susceptible
d'influencer mentalement la perception
que vous avez de votre douleur c'est
comme quand vous étiez petit ou petit
que vous tombiez et que vous aviez pas
mal jusqu'au moment où vous voyez que
vous avez les jeunes on s'en fou alors à
l'inversé que vous avez hyper mal et que
quelqu'un arrive à faire diversion en
vous parlant d'un truc qui vous
intéresse énormément et du coup vous
oubliez que vous avez mal alors ya aussi
tout un tas d'autres trucs qui rentre en
compte la comme notre conception
personnelle de la douleur par exemple où
notre expérience personnelle de la
douleur et pour finir il ya la
composante comportementale c'est notre
façon d'exprimer la douleur et essaie
aussi influencé par tout un tas de trucs
notre expérience personnelle de la
douleur encore mais il ya aussi des
facteurs générationnel et puis l'autre
qui dépendent de notre éducation notre
culture etc donc quand on sait tout ça
on comprend bien pourquoi tout le monde
ressent pas et n'exprime pas la douleur
de la même façon mais par contre
attention tout le monde a mal oui tout
le monde a mal les gens abdulle est
qu'ils font pas du cinéma ils ont
vraiment mal ils ressentent vraiment la
douleur ils la ressentent et l'expriment
différemment des personnes pas
douillettes mais ils ont vraiment mal
donc il faut pas minimiser la douleur de
qui que ce soit n'y a pas de fausses ou
de vraies douleurs il ya juste la
douleur tout le monde a mal enfin tout
le monde a mal sauf sauf les gens qui ne
ressentent pas la douleur
oui ça existe et non c'est pas un super
pouvoir c'est une maladie ça peut même
être la conséquence de plusieurs comme
lé insensibilité congénitale à la
douleur par exemple c'est une maladie
génétique du système nerveux qui a été
décrite pour la première fois en 1932
les patients laisse avec une incapacité
ressentir de la douleur parce que leur
fibre nocifs et activent ne se sont pas
développés correctement vous souvenez
les fibres no 6 et steve c'est les
récepteurs de la douleur il yad'autres
atteinte du système nerveux qui peuvent
arriver au même résultat mais n'allez
pas vous imaginer que c'est cool de pas
ressentir la douleur on l'a vu la
douleur c'est un signal d'alarmé c'est
une alerte agression et si la larme
fonctionne pas le réflexe de sauvegarde
non plus par exemple on retire pas sa
main du feu parce qu'on ne sent pas que
ça brûle et si au bout du compte le
cerveau non plus et pas au courant qu'il
se passe quelque chose de pas normal eh
ben on va rien faire pour que ça
s'arrête et on risque d'avoir des
séquelles de plus en plus grands les
nouveau-nés ressentent la douleur alors
oui je vous vois faire les malins genre
un timbre indom bien sûr n'empêche que
dans les années 50 on lisait encore dans
les manuels de médecine pour pouvait
opérer les nouveau nés sans anesthésie
jusqu'à quatre jours après leur
naissance et qu'il a fallu attendre 1987
pour qu'on admette que les nouveau nés
sont capables de ressentir la douleur
1987 jusqu alors pensé qu'ils avaient
pas mal parce que leur système nerveux
et est immature à la naissance ce n'est
pas complètement faux techniquement
parce que le cerveau par exemple
continue à se développer après la
naissance par contre le système de la
douleur lui il est déjà fonctionnel on
peut se faire opérer sous hypnose
l'hypnose ça marche sur la douleur
attention y'a pas messmer qui va se
pointer dans le bloc opératoire et vous
endormir pour qu on vous retire un
organe pourri c'est pas comme ça que ça
marche mais l'hypnose ça peut être
utilisé par les médecins pour agir sur
toutes les composantes de la douleur
sensitive émotionnelles cognitives et
comportementales ou sommeil et du coup
en agissant sur toutes les composantes
de la douleur par magie sur la douleur
qui diminue c'est ce qu'on appelle
hypnosédations ou l'hypno anesthésie
c'est à dire le fait de soulager
d'apaiser la douleur par l'hypnose c'est
de l'hypnose médicale donc c'est
pratiqué par des professionnels de santé
qui ont été spécialement formés à cet
effet pas de l'hypnose de spectacle on
va pas vous faire faire la poule après
s'il veut mettre son envie de se marrer
un peu parfois ça peut remplacer
complètement une anesthésie dans
certains cas mais souvent c'est en plus
c'est utilisé pour améliorer
l'efficacité des autres traitements
contre la douleur d'ailleurs ya plein
d'autres moyens de soulager la douleur
on en reparlera dans une autre vidéo de
cette série si ça vous de force personne
la pire douleur du monde c'est assez
compliqué parce qu'on a vu la douleur
c'est subjectif mais il ya eu plusieurs
tentatives de classement par des
institutions ou par des universités par
exemple qui à l'université de mcgill à
montréal qui a mis au point un
questionnaire d'évaluation de la douleur
hyper détaillés qui à destination des
patients alors a permis d'établir une
sorte de classement des pires douleurs
décrites et au final le podium c'est en
3 l'accouchement oui c'est très très
haut dans le classement quand même j'ai
jamais expérimenté personnellement ce
type de douleur donc je vais laisser une
personne concernée la décrire
en deux la piqûre de paratonnerre ac
l'avatar la fourmi balle de fusil là
encore je laisse une personne concernée
vous raconter
et en tête à la première place sur la
plus haute marche
la médaille d'or le kylie ann m bape et
de la douleur le syndrome douloureux
régional complexe cherchez pas vous
connaissez pas alors c'est quoi eh bah
c'est une douleur neuropathique c'est à
dire une douleur causée par un
dysfonctionnement du système nerveux ça
peut avoir plein de causes différentes
parfois on en retrouve même aucune mais
ça arrive souvent après un traumatisme
au niveau d'une main ou d'un pied par
exemple et on sait pas encore exactement
pourquoi mais la douleur au lieu de
diminuer progressivement et puis de
disparaître eh ben elle augmente elle
augmente c'est à dire que ça devient
beaucoup plus douloureux que le
traumatisme de base et puis la douleur
s'installe avec en plus tout un tas
d'autres symptômes qui peuvent durer
plusieurs années et qui peut même
s'étendre voilà on va pas rentrer dans
le détail mais ça illustre bien la
variété de couleurs différentes qui
existent même parmi les plus fortes si
ça vous intéresse un de ces jours on
regardera classement d'un peu plus près
la douleur c'est pas normal on a
toujours eu un rapport un peu spéciale
avec la douleur pour plein de raisons tu
es la douleur rédemptrice tous à
souffrir c'est bien c'est courageux faut
souffrir pour être belle il faut
souffrir pour être beau si ça fait mal
c'est que ça fait du bien que de la
merde d'après l'inserm la douleur c'est
le motif de deux tiers des consultations
médicales enfants et on estime qu'une
personne sur trois souffre de 12
chronique et pourtant je suis sûr qu'un
jour ou l'autre quelqu'un vous a déjà
dit non mais ça va c'est normal d'avoir
mal alors soyons clairs non c'est pas
normal on a vu la douleur c'est un
signal d'alarmé pour prévenir qu'il ya
quelque chose qui va pas donc c'est une
réaction normale ce qui est anormal
c'est de laisser les gens avoir mal
parce qu'on a tout un tas de façons
d'évaluer la douleur déjà et puis de la
soulager mais encore une fois on
reparlera de tout ça dans les vidéos
suivantes mais sachez quand même que
l'article l 1110 5 du code de la santé
publique indique très clairement que
toute personne a le droit de recevoir
des soins visant à soulager sa douleur
celle ci doit être en toutes
circonstances prévenus et vaslui est
prise en compte prévenus ça veut dire
faire de la prévention autour de la
douleur parce que normalement quand on a
mal on est prévenu pour finir sachez que
la douleur c'est considéré comme une
urgence médicale donc non c'est jamais
normal qu'on voulait savoir mal c'est
comme si vous aviez un accident et qu'on
vous disait la vie mais c'est normal de
mourir la douleur c'est pas normal sauf
sauf si on aime ça là c'est pas pareil
on en a déjà parlé vos fantasmes coquine
tu vaux qui fait tu sais ça regarde que
vous et personne a jugé sa juste
attention là je parle de bdsm un don des
trucs déjà entre adultes consentants et
puis je parle pas de se faire du mal
parce qu'on se sent mal par exemple là
ça s'appelle de l'automutilation et
c'est le signe qu'il faut en parler avec
sfr voient la dtcc fini pour aujourd'hui
oubliez pas de me donner vos idées de
noms pour cette série sur la douleur on
se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez vous bien
et surtout portez vous bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]